port so there you are walking along
minding your own business a perfect
example of Manliness covered in the
greatest of armor when all of the sudden
Oh No
mouthy ell nothing could stop my hunger
to be done no mal Theo you douche I will
get revenge diablo 3 reaper of souls is
the latest expansion to diablo 3 a game
which i have played for well over 300
hours so I've been tasked with teaching
you guys what you need to do in this new
diablo 3 reaper souls expansion well you
got a level kappa 70 you got a new class
called the crusader who's pretty much
awesome i a new adventure mode that's
totally awesome and randomized and
cooler let you go through the world
boo baboo baboo and kill things dead and
then you got more itemization which
allows you to get better stuff I mean
just look at me I'm I'm gorgeous I'm
beautiful I'm high oh look at my gear
it's awesome but anyway you can always
do better so you gotta get out there and
kill some things take their stuff and
insult them while they're dead
yay okay so here's your character you
got your guy he's got no eyes armor he
looks cool and all that and you want to
go kill some bad guys because they had
the mutant you want that sorry I hit the
microphone but that's okay you go over
there and you go you go see him and
you're like whew I'm gonna get you you
son of a [ __ ]
oh how where's mousey Elphaba did you
punch a bit punch a bit button they're
dead good and you did it and you do that
a hundred more times until you get to
mouth heal and then you punch him in his
face and you take all of his things
that's when again for taking your candy
what a what a dick what what a douche
okay so that's more of the basic aspects
of Diablo you need to get into the now
advanced aspects of Diablo so you got to
open up your inventory and look at the
the loot you just looted out of you know
the enemy's bones and bowels your ripest
acts out of there and look at it yeah
that's got a good axe that is real good
it's it's better than whatever the hell
I was using before get rid of that just
death kick that to the curb that's no
good
so you you get rid of that and you put
that new one on who you are you feel
powerful you feel your numbers get
bigger and everything oh so when your
numbers thicket you dip da da you gave
you up so you go out to the Oasis and
then you go back to town and then you go
talk to Tyrael and he tells you what
you're supposed to do and so you need to
go back out to the Oasis or go to the
desert maybe and then you go back to
town dr. Theriot again cuz you're not
sure what you're supposed to do there
you go talk to the blacksmith he tells
you to talk to Tyrael again here you'll
getting kind of pissed off now you go
back outside you go back inside still
lost you go back to Tyrael but Daryl's
mad at you for some reason you don't
know what you did so you go over out
back again mouth back in out in and out
in and out in and out and you go talk to
this guy and and I don't know why he's
here seems like a bit of a douche but I
mean that's besides boiling then you go
talk to Tyrael again but Tyrael doesn't
want to talk to you anymore and you're
like Dario come on let's talk about our
problems we can work this out we're two
grown-ups we can do this but then Tyrael
sends you on you got to go find and then
you're dead and so when you're dead you
are dead forever
don't get rid of that guy just delete
him to lead him right there he's gone
forever good didn't want to see him
anyway
so then you move on you're gonna die a
lot and that's gonna be the end of it
pretty much
yep diablo 3 reaper of souls so anyway
that's about it i mean i've taught you
everything that i could possibly teach
you all my years of experience playing
this game is now yours so take it and go
kill monsters and take their stuff it's
gonna be a lot of fun so i'll see when
the game comes out thanks for watching
bye bye